foreign
you've been smart with your Acquisitions
I want to jump ahead go ahead I think
that was a Savvy strategy you employed
during the 2008 financial crisis
obviously not a good time for housing
the housing market the market that
depends on the goods that you sell can
you talk about what you did then because
you have referred to it as the biggest
risk you've ever taken you could feel
that recession coming on
it was it was very scary so it really
became evident that we were in a
recession in late of 2008 2009 and we
had about 250 locations at that time
there was a acquisition that came
available
and it was Bradco
and there was no way
I could oversee that acquisition at that
time I had to take on a partner an
investment partner and I had to give up
40 some percent of my shares
and uh
we've always owned everything but this
one was
one that I knew that I knew the company
and it had to be done and it really is
painful to give up control and to bring
in investment bankers but if I could
give them the return like they always
want to return within five years I would
buy my shares back
did you buy your shares back yes
we bought them back in three three and a
half years and I still get strippers
right now
because I felt I had risked the company
that I wanted my children to run when
we're not here you know it's it's not a
company that's ever going to be for sale
to make that acquisition at that time
during a recession
was I was felt like I was risking it all
but I knew that I knew that it was a
good company we were buying and has
proven to be one of the best
Acquisitions we ever did but you can't
see into the future
you can't see that far into the future
so it was it was it was difficult but I
have a great team had a great team then
and everybody believed that we could get
it done and I you have to trust trust
your experts within the companies that
we have and we did it
[Music]